welcome to this video let's play the
Saline in this splits game hands down
tomorrowland from the US not sure that i
ever played him on tees maybe in
tomorrowland but never solve the sodium
before okay yeah against the clothes you
can play all kinds of lines I like this
a 6-line it sound interesting that dumb
completely prevents this grand prix
attack issues interesting he takes on d5
likes this look so strange in my eyes I
mean only it seems very weakening okay
I'm so yeah the problem is some if you
this exchange simply exposes some the
e-file especially the e3 square so on
can not afford some I take twice the
lucky one num I let me trouble on the
evil but okay 95 would be normal but
maybe can go see form C 4 C 3 something
like that interesting I can also just
take I mean this take once and then we
should be seven it doesn't really
threaten my position much okay
yeah whatever you think about his movies
playing quickly yeah just 96 on 97 hmm
can also take okay let's get rid of this
Sam that's not so I got I got the Jeep
on and um yeah it so I think white quite
a comfortable position don't think I'm
in any kind of trouble here ruki item
wants to play against you for porn okay
can just retreat
maybe its own medicine it's wrong to
equal this position attending ruka da
dun down maybe d3 in some cases but he
prevented this okay so I could I could
go on Bishop f8 but okay first let Sam
give some support to the deep one and um
I don't really see what what why display
is yes this is you can do but it's not
i'm not doing so much I think doubling
on the c4 I'm now maybe now it's not
ready yet taking on e4 and d3 check em
it's not not a thread yet but something
to to look at what about Queen to Queen
to g6 or to supplying then f5 not quite
sure if I've looks I'm a very weakening
can just drop back then and uh huh
interesting just just attacking this
rook if i go to be seven okay he's also
covering the the basic square i get that
a question is what if I just still just
a key i mean at the anti screen is
saying with rupee one check ideas okay
don't see why I shouldn't shouldn't do
that Bishop d8 I just play weekly one
check and this King looks really am
somewhat insecure I don't ya okay this
is so this is one idea but i thought i
would have enough play against this king
with them 22 for example maybe m this
was bad bad judgment call teruki eight
is very quick here
yeah just ticking this rook I mean Mary
the problem is rook e8 at some point
just threatens also looked xf8 so on
this can be M be problematical really
quickly I think I need to make some sun
roof tier for the King to age 7 and hope
for the D porn ok I can play Bishop time
is heaven now of course and then I need
to try d 3 hoping that this is enough
counter play and his pieces a bit loose
did ya d to e wants a play Bishop to b4
check so I get out of this yea gads bit
unlucky man he never played any of this
and just fall into his hands yeah maybe
it was a bad idea to take on your phone
and get to this to the some material
imbalance or how to tell
yeah this is fairly easy one time when I
mean for right of course is the one with
the extra piece yeah also resign but
yeah yeah now he tells me boom yeah I
suspected he wasn't the brightest Under
the Sun yeah okay let's um let's just
check this quickly maybe yeah love it um
okay OOP takes e4 58 can't problem is
this is just bad
before I thought Queen d2 here but I'm
probably this doesn't really help let's
give this a quick a quick check with the
computer yeah why does so clearly better
after rook c8 age 6 s earned the
computer move and this this probably
losses so I was I was intending this but
then I saw that rupee aid is a problem
with the intention just to sac rope
takes fa tendencies this is some the
problem here actually the computer gives
us as playable after age six look at
eight King age 7 and I have counter play
but yeah i get b 2 and a 2 it's probably
bad for black but down but maybe still
still playable yeah anyway this was
wasn't necessary at all in this position
i can just play rooty seven or something
this is just just too much probably also
um white can win in this position Google
with Bishop takes e4 interesting let's
just check this quickly so look the
bishop pixie fall from my side was bad
anyway so this and now f5 okay Queen
takes rook f1a now rook e1 is not a
check okay so after Queen g6 the rookies
just saying so I just blundered the rook
here yeah very bad game from my side
just uh I just must just must go here
and then it's a just a game it's nothing
special happening you know the pawn is
hanging now and
yeah maybe just rupee won something and
the normal game yeah thanks for watching